[Music]
everyone its Alicia Malone welcome to
another episode of Fandango indie movie
guide let's get straight into it with a
really fun shootout called free fire
they're gonna put the guns right here
when they are done they're gonna leave
then Tweedledee and Tweedledum can load
them up into your little clown car
you're the first one I'm gonna take down
of this ghost sighs but none it's
probably good idea grandpa I'm sorry you
just you're molting
this is directed by ben wheatley who did
kill list and sightseers it's set in the
70s and the basic premise is that it's
an arms deal that goes horribly wrong
leading to this massive shootout all set
in the one location and I'm a big sucker
for movies that are set in the one
location because not only does it
increase the tension but also because
you don't have as much to work with it's
really focused on the characters and the
story you've got two choices one you
distract him and hanif what the
characters here are great and the
mixture of violence and humor is sure to
remind a lot of people of Tarantino and
though the gunfire does go on for a
little bit long it's a fun time at the
cinema go and see free fire this weekend
it's opening wide which means everyone
can see it
we can't all be nice girls
[Music]
well everyone in America but another
film that's out this weekend is called
unforgettable this is a drama mystery
starring Katherine Heigl she plays a
mother whose ex-husband gets together
with a new woman and all hell breaks
loose where's your ring
how come you in the lair who sent you
flowers she's messing with me David this
is the directorial debut for producer
Denis denovi she is a woman who's been
working in Hollywood for many years she
produced a lot of films with Tim Burton
also films like Heather's and produced
Crazy Stupid Love with all of her
accomplishments I thought she would be
the perfect person to start spotlight on
women in film Denis was so lovely to
talk to so here's a bit of my chat with
Denis Genova I feel like this movie in
particular is helped by having a female
director because that idea of a crazy
woman can easily you know be
misconstrued it needs to have that
special touch would you say that's
correct I agree I mean I tried very hard
to bring dimension to the role that
Katherine Heigl plays the role of Tessa
I was very important to me that you have
compassion for the character that you
understand where she comes from you
understand what personally and kind of
socially of the social conditioning that
has created you know this situation
where she went so far so I do think
because I related to a lot of the things
she is dealing with in the movie I did
give it a different nuanced and maybe
some more depth I was saying before him
and sometimes doing interviews I feel
like I have to prove to the person I'm
interviewing that I know what I'm
talking about because I'm young and a
woman without being a producer there
times when you felt like you had to
prove yourself because of your gender a
long time ago yes I mean when I started
there were very few
a handful less than a handful of women
producers you know I didn't even know
about well you know women producers or
if there were any and when I started I
did come against a lot of pushback and
that I just kind of you know didn't take
no for an answer to it didn't make sense
to me hmm
I didn't see any reason why I shouldn't
do what I wanted to do and make films I
couldn't see any logic in it so I
thought you know what eventually I'm
just gonna push through this yep and
luckily it happened the thing that's the
most exciting to me is that there's a
lot of conversation we're talking about
it right now
the more that we talk about it the more
you know women speak up about it and the
more conversations we have the more I
think people's inherent sense of justice
and decency
it'll prevail they just need to be
educated and think about it like people
ask me do you mind being called a woman
director and I don't until you know
women are half of the directing
population or half of the producing
population we need to point it out so
that people can acknowledge and validate
it and support it if you can see it you
can Bay it exactly I love that phrase
yeah thank you so much for everything
that you do and for joining us something
thank you thank you
she is so inspirational and I can't wait
to continue spotlight on women in film
so this weekend go to see free-fire the
crazy shootout or unforgettable the
twisted drama and tell me what you have
seen in the comments below or on Twitter
at Alicia Malone I'll see you soon
you